[Musik]
hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es mal eine etwas andere
novick torte aus dem kühlschrank die ist
nämlich mit soft case oft das ist diese
süßigkeit hier
da gibt es auch schon ein rezept zum
nachmachen also ein original treff zelle
auf meinem kanal
ihr könnt jetzt entweder die
selbstgemachten nehmen oder die aus der
verpackung und diese torte machen
unten habe ich einen krampf boden an der
seite dieses oft keks die könnt ihr auch
gerne wenn ihr wollt noch in die mitte
geben ihnen ist noch ein frucht kern und
dann eine orangen muss richtig lecker
für den noten brauche ich 50 gramm
gehackte mandeln 65 gramm butter und 145
gramm kekse damit die mandeln einen
schönen geschmack bekommen müsste ich
sie jetzt erst mal in einem topf vor
sich dass sie nicht verbrennen
und die zwischenzeit kann ich nutzen und
schon mal die kekse zerkleinern
[Musik]
jetzt riechen die mandeln richtig lecker
und sehen auch richtig gut aus haben
farbe bekommen
die hitze reicht jetzt auch aus um die
butter zu schmelzen und dann höre ich da
noch die kekse 1
jetzt game six master in meinen
tortenring den habe ich bereits auf 22
zentimeter durchmesser eingestellt ich
gucke da immer zuerst auf solche
tortenplatte ich die torte stellen will
und dann suche ich dementsprechend die
torte aus jetzt drücke ich den boden
schönen fest und federn den boden ein so
wieder am schnellsten fest und ich kann
in der zwischenzeit schon mal die creme
verbreiten
[Musik]
für das orange lebendig 300 milliliter
orangensaft etwas aka aka hier habe ich
es oft text die brauche ich für den rand
und für die füllung dann für die moz
etwa 300 milliliter orangensaft 60
milliliter wasser
ich habe ich gemalt der gelatine 2 weiß
60 gramm zucker und 250 milliliter sahne
jetzt stelle ich zuerst im kern her da
für verhöre ich den orangensaft mit dem
acker in einem topf und lasse jetzt den
saft zwei minuten sprudelnd kochen damit
der saft schneller abkühlt völlig hin
zum jetzt ist er nur noch lauwarm und
ich mache immer gerne lehrprobe das
heißt ich gebe einen esslöffel von der
masse auf einen teller sowie hier habe
dann kurz im kühlschrank gestellt und
dann sieht man schon das wird richtig
schön fest ich will das ganze jetzt hier
eine silikonform dann habe ich einen
schönen tag später muss man sich
vorstellen dass kommt und so leicht
gebogen raus ihr könnt aber auch das
ganze zum beispiel ihren teller füllen
also einfach nur normale frucht einlage
machen
ihr könnt da einfach vorher
frischhaltefolie rhein geben
das wird jetzt kurzen eingefahren und
dann kann ich nämlich schon das moos
herstellen den punkt kann habe ich jetzt
mit agatha hergestellt die muss stelle
ich jetzt mit gelatine her
die könnt ihr auch mit acker machen aber
die muss wird einfach ein bisschen
lockerer wenn man das hat ihnen nimmt
und dann nehme ich dann die gemahlene
ich nehme es einfach den gleichen topf
wie gerade eben gibt in u-haft rein
lasst ihn jetzt aufkochen und dann ein
bisschen reduzieren damit das wasser
verdunstet und während hier der
orangensaft verdunstet kann ich schon
mal die gelatine verrühren
da habe ich eine rinne gelatine dies
auch halal da kommt jetzt wasser rein
und dann muss die so etwa zehn minuten
quellen und jetzt kann ich schon mal die
sahne steif schlagen und kurz in den
kühlschrank stellen
der orangensaft robert noch ganz fleißig
und ich kann jetzt auch schon weil das
eiweiß verrühren
das kommt jetzt nicht roh in die torte
sondern wird mit dem zucker verrühren
und dann über ein heißes wasserbad
gestellt und verweist 60 grad erreicht
hat er hätte ich es einfach immer weiter
so erst nach fünf bis zehn minuten dass
es auch schön schreibt wird und dann
werden auch die keime abgetötet und die
braucht dass sie jetzt keinen
thermometer sondern stellt einfach aufs
kochen wildwasserbahn und dann ereignis
orientiert also hier kurz berühren kann
ich schon mal hier auf den kopf stellen
das wasser kocht gleich und sobald das
wasser kocht bisschen runter stellen
damit der schnee auch nicht gerinnt und
dann wirklich etwa fünf bis zehn minuten
rühren
[Musik]
jetzt ist der effekt hätten sich ihm
gleich kalt rühren
ich kann es aber ganz kurz hier stehen
lassen und ihm ist echt aufpassen dass
das wasser nicht zu doll ob damit
wirklich der schnee nicht gerinnt
ich habe ich jetzt den orangensaft und
jetzt darf die masse nicht mehr kochen
mit gelatine das ist ganz wichtig dass
auch der große unterschied zwischen
gelatine und agger dieses schön kroll
kommt hier rein und wird kurz eingerührt
[Musik]
jetzt lasse ich das ganze ganz kurz
lauwarm abkühlen und so lange kann ich
bin ein klassischer fitnesstag soll erst
die kalorien verbrennen und dann wieder
drauf hauen
jetzt kann die torte gefüllt werden die
soft facts nehme ich jetzt und legte mit
dem schoko rand nach außen hier auf den
teig
[Musik]
da kommt jetzt der frucht boden drauf da
ist es einfacher wenn er komplett
gefroren ist meiner ist jetzt einfach
nur schockiert aber es klappt trotzdem
wunderbar lücke gefüllt
und jetzt muss ich die muss her stellen
die habe ich das eiweiß ich will ein
bisschen bis ich fertig gebaut hat
wenn nämlich ein bisschen was vom eis
schnee und es kommt jetzt zum saft dazu
damit einfach die gelatine nicht sofort
arbeitet und jetzt kommt das wieder hier
zurück und bis langsam eingerührt
[Musik]
und hier habe ich jetzt noch die sonne
unter dann ist das alles fertig sieht
man auch schauen wie die creme gleich
ansieht und bisschen fester wird und im
kühlschrank wird für dann ganz fest so
gut dass muss jetzt in die torte
[Musik]
so kann die torte dann in den
kühlschrank für etwa vier bis sechs
stunden wissen schon fest ist wer sich
den part mit dem eiweiss und der statine
sparen möchte kann auch agar agar nehmen
mit dem orangensaft und zum beispiel
frischkäse oder quark schott eiweiß aber
so wird er wirklich eine richtig schöne
und lockere muss dies oft keks torte
löse ich jetzt aus dem back ring heraus
und geht jetzt einfach nur noch ein
bisschen öko drauf dafür schneide ich
die soft facts klein und streu sie noch
an den rand
[Musik]
man kann die torte echt wunderbar
schneiden sie hält wunderbar und ich
finde das sieht aus wie so eine sonne
die aufgeht da unten probieren telekom
auf jeden fall eine torte die man machen
sollte
falls ihr das rezept findet ihr es auch
sallys - blog.de ich freue mich schon
auf eure soft tactics und wir sehen uns
wieder beim nächsten mal hallo ich bin
kate and the waves of cake softs of cake
zurück heisst nicht kennt
[Musik]